[Music]
today I'm starting a new video series
called the basics it will consist of
five to ten videos designed to teach you
the fundamentals of angular six to kick
things off we're going to start with one
of the most powerful features of angular
which is the CLI a ton of new features
were added to the CLI in version 6 and
my goal is to show you how to use it
effectively to dramatically speed up the
development time of your app if you're
new to the channel make sure to LIKE and
subscribe and grab the full source code
from angular firebase comm so the main
goal of angular's command-line interface
is to automate things that you would
otherwise have to do manually and it
does a really good job of that compared
to what other web frameworks offer the
reason I chose it as the topic for this
first basics video is because you really
need to know how to use the CLI before
you can use angular effectively to get
started you want to bring up a command
line terminal which I'm doing here in vs
code then run npm install angular CLI
flag global that should install version
6.0 or greater on your system giving you
access to the ng command you can verify
the install by running an ng flag v
which will print out some information
about your local development environment
then the first command that you'll run
is ng new the new command will generate
all of the boilerplate code that you
need to start a brand new angular
project from scratch you'll go ahead and
say ng new with the name of your app and
then there's a number of different
options that you can pass in with the
command let's say you want to use a CSS
extension you can simply pass in the
style flag along with sass last stylist
or whatever you want to use and if you
want to take advantage of angular's
router you can pass in the routing
option and that will automatically
generate the router for you there's a
bunch of other options which you can
check out on the documentation on github
but I use these two options very
frequently when you execute this command
it's going to generate a new directory
based on the name of your app then it
creates all the files necessary to build
and test an angular app now that we've
created this directory we'll go ahead
and run code with the name of that
directory to open the project up into vs
code if you're not using vs code just
open up the project in your IDE as you
can see here we have all of our files
generated and all of our node modules
install
but there's one filed it's special when
it comes to the COI and that's the
angular JSON file for right now we don't
have to modify anything inside this file
but just know that it exists to control
the behavior of the CLI as you become a
more advanced angular user you'll be
able to do some very powerful things
here to build your own libraries control
the build process of your app and build
your own custom schematics for
boilerplate code but we'll cover that
stuff in a more advanced video what we
want to do next is make sure that our
app works properly by running ng serve
run the command from the command line
and add the a flag to have it
automatically open up in your browser
the command will compile all of your
code with webpack and then spin up a web
server so we can view it on localhost
4200 and the cool thing about it is that
it will rebuild your code on every
change let's go into the source code for
this app in the app component and
instead of saying welcome to title we'll
say hello world title when we make our
changes we see them instantly reflected
on the app itself now that we have a
working skeleton app let's look at how
we can generate boilerplate code to
build our component services pipes etc
when you call generate you're pointing
to a schematic a schematic can be
thought of as a template that has some
specific rules that can be followed
based on the command-line arguments that
you pass to it every schematic takes a
different set of arguments and we can
figure out what those arguments are by
running an NG generate with the
schematic name in this case component
and then flag help as you can see here
it prints out a bunch of different
options that we can pass in to this
schematic when it generates the code for
us this is an important concept because
it's not just generating the files for
us it's also putting them in a specific
spot and updating the other files that
depend on them for example in angular we
have a concept of modules so when we
generate a component we need to declare
that component in its parent module so
let's look at the most common use case
we'll run ng generate component and give
it a name of cool you'll notice that it
creates four different files but it also
updates our existing app module as you
can see here it added the cool component
to the deck
in the ng module and also handled the
typescript import for us so it
eliminates those tedious little things
that are necessary for the app to work
then if we look in the cool directory
you can see it generated our component
files that we can use to start writing
code immediately without having to do
any boilerplate setup once you get
comfortable with the CLI you'll be able
to shorten these commands with aliases
for example you might run ng generate
component neat then we'll tell it not to
generate our testing file then we'll
also give it an inline template and an
inline style sheet with the T and s
flags just like before it generated the
component directory and updated the app
module but this time it only generated
one file because we told it to use an
inline template and style sheet so all
of that code is contained directly in
the component type script that just
shows you how the CLI can give you
flexibility based on your developer
preferences as an angular developer one
thing you should be doing is
compartmentalizing your code into ng
modules by default the CLI will import a
component that's generated into your
route app module but what if you're
trying to generate a component for a
feature module let's see how we might
handle that first we'll generate a
module called
awesome now let's say we want to add a
pipe to this module called lower case
there are two different ways we can
handle this the most straightforward way
is to just generate this pipe in the
same directory as our awesome module
when doing that the CLI is smart enough
to know to import this pipe in the
awesome module and not the route app
module like it normally would but
sometimes your component might be in a
different directory so there's another
way to add it to the module and we can
do that by simply running the same
command but adding the end flag for
module and then point it to the awesome
module this pipe is generated outside of
the awesome directory but it still gets
imported properly and declared in the
awesome module so just to reiterate the
generate command is super powerful and
there's a bunch of built-in schematics
that handle most of the boilerplate code
generation that you'll need an angular
and you can even use custom schematics
for third-party angular libraries such
as ng rx so now that we've generated all
this code how are we going to test it
one of the great things about the CLI is
that it
automatically sets you up for
test-driven development all we have to
do is run ng test and it's going to pull
up this test runner in the browser which
is powered by karma and Jasmine every
time you run the generate command it
creates a spec file that you can use to
test the code that you generated so far
we have seven specs and they're all
passing except for one if you remember
earlier we changed the title from
welcome to app to hello world app and
that's causing our specs to fail just
like ng serve this will automatically
run our specs on every file change so if
we change this back to welcome two it's
going to rerun all the tests and you see
this time all of them pass the next
thing we're going to look at is an
awesome new feature called ng add which
was introduced in angular 6 it allows
you to add third-party packages or
libraries with zero configuration for
example if we want to make our angular
app a progressive web app there is
normally a bunch of files that we would
have to create manually but now we can
just run ng add at angular PWA and it's
going to create all these files for us
automatically in previous videos I've
showed you how to setup PWA is an
angular but now with ng add those videos
are pretty much obsolete because we can
just run this command and it will
generate the Service Worker config file
it will install the dependencies for us
and it will also generate the icons
necessary to be a valid PWA
but ng adds not limited to just packages
created by the angular team any
third-party library can create its own
schematics to automatically add it as a
dependency to an angular project let's
take a look at the ng bootstrap library
normally to install this we would have
to run npm install and then import it
into our app module then called a for
root method on that module but with ng
add we can skip this entire process and
just handle all these steps with a
single command from the CLI run ng add
ng bootstrap slash schematics this
installs the package via NPM and then
also handles the import steps in our app
module again this is brand new and
angular 6 so there's not many packages
that have this functionality but we'll
definitely see a lot more of this in the
coming year
now the last thing we're going to look
at is ng build once you finish writing
all your code you'll need a way to
package and bundle your app so it can be
deployed to a web host when you run ng
build flag prod it's going to minify and
optimize your code and tree shake away
any dead code that would make your
bundle size larger than necessary in
other words it's going to package your
app to be as performant as possible for
the end user the final code can be found
here in the distal der and this is what
you would actually deploy to a web host
for example if you were using something
like firebase you could just run
firebase deploy and point it to this
dist folder and again your entire build
process can be customized in the angular
JSON file if you look under architect
build configurations you'll see one for
production with all the options required
for our production build so those are
the core features of the angular CLI but
let's look at a few other tricks that it
has up its sleeve let's imagine we have
an existing app that's on an older
version of angular and we want to update
it in angular 6 we now have this ng
update command which will update all of
our NPM packages to the latest and
greatest version of angular or what if
we're stuck and we want to look up
something in the documentation we can
simply run ng doc with the search term
that we want to search and that will
open up the angular Doc's so we never
have to leave the command-line yet
another way that the CLI makes your life
a little bit easier I'm gonna go ahead
and wrap things up there if this video
helped you please like and subscribe and
if you're serious about building apps
with angular consider becoming a pro
member at angular firebase com you'll
get access to exclusive content that you
won't find anywhere else
designed to help you build and ship your
app faster thanks for watching and
see you soon
[Music]